one of my favorites from working back in
the day at the worldwide leader in
sports part of MLB network's coverage of
Game two of the Yankees and Indians
today at 5:00 Eastern Time visit MLB
network.com for your local channel
listings Peter Gammons here on the Rich
Eisen show how are you Peter I'm doing
very well rich this is this is I think
the best potentially the best postseason
from wildcard to finish I think that in
a long time I agree with you Peter
I agree those 2-1 gamers were really
entertaining you know I I wish we had a
little bit more competitive games in the
first two games of the ALDS is yesterday
but anybody I truly feel anybody can win
it based on if the ball bounces their
way and their strengths can be played up
thanks to whatever's going on on the
scoreboard I agree I mean and I start
with it
I thought the Arizona Colorado game yeah
you know somebody was kidding me about
it so I thought they for two teams not
just one but in terms of two teams in
the WAC since they instituted the wild
card playing game I thought these are
the two best teams that played each
other I mean those are really good teams
and really dangerous and I mean it's the
only problem for Arizona is the impact
in that they had to use Bobby Ray out of
the bullpen and so instead of pushing
against Kershaw tonight Robby ray will
have to wait until the second third game
which is he was so good close the most
unhittable starting pitcher in the
National League that that changes the
series a little bit but still I mean
that game was I mean you can replay that
for like they're kind of reminded me if
i NC st. beating maryland back in the
eighties double overtime nice I do like
that and let's talk about the NLDS is
since we you know we've been very
American League centric with those two
games we those two games yesterday and
obviously the wild-card on
on Tuesday everybody sleeping on the
Cubs Peter I really believe that my
question is is how realistic are their
repeat hopes from you I think they have
a better chance than a lot of people do
right I mean last year you just seen as
if you know they doesn't know left lane
and no I ever stopped them from Pro
driving you know is unless laying all
you know the whole year and a substance
it was in a series of the Indians but
Washington's really good I mean when you
start out with Strasburg and you've got
Scherzer going in Game three
they're really good but Kyle Hendricks
is really good too and a very
interesting change of speeds pitcher
who's been great in the second half who
might be able to throw Washington lineup
off a little bit and then you know we
will see will Lester we have no idea of
whether or not area it's going to be
able to pitch but I mean that's they're
they're difficult I picked up they're
they're they're telling the pile of
Washington's team in the field and you
know if Harper's timing is down that
change that can change a series and I
think rundown was maybe the most
underrated great player in this series
but the same time defensive problems I
mean Murphy at second
Zimmerman's flowing problems I mean I
wouldn't be surprised at all if a few
times in this series guys just take off
in a pitcher stores lose the first and
see if Zimmerman can throw the ball to
second because that's an issue and that
they they the Cubs are going to exploit
that kind of thing so I think this has a
chance to be a great series and I feel
better about the Astros if they were
going Greinke Rea but still they're
they're very good in terms of their
calendar the field and I worry a lot
about the Dodgers bullpen leading up to
Campbell chance and I I just I mean to
take Alex wood and start him I get why
because really don't feel ready to start
but at the same time I think they need
Alex wood in the bullpen is that the
whole lead-up situation
to get to gentleness can be very shaky
and I just I get a little afraid of
watching a couple of those relievers
Peter Gammons of MLB Network joining us
just as the first pitch is getting
thrown in Game two between the Red Sox
and the Astros and then the Yankee
strength is that bullpen as we saw a
very very rare instance of trying to
protect a game from the third of from a
third of an inning on the only issue
with that being the Yankee strengths in
many ways is they've got to get a lead
and I don't know if they're gonna be
able to get one against the Cleveland
Indians who looks so very good Peter how
good is this
Indians team compared to World Series
champs that you've eyeballed in the past
yeah one of their one of the best and I
and and the thing is that their pitching
is so deep
I mean I velu you know always thinking
okay what are you concerned about my
concern about Cody Allen you know what
20 and he's in LA one of the postseason
last year and he just throws a little
bit but they're starting to see they
didn't have Salazar or Carrasco actually
a couple of exit Indians were who played
on that team last year arguing the
Carrasco is actually better than Kluber
I'm not sure I get that yet but we shall
see
I mean kolosso is really good and
they're so deep for Trevor Bauer yeah
sometimes one of the things about
baseball I'm sure you see a lot football
to where they come out of the drafts and
expectations are so high but III think
that the attention span of development
people sometimes and managers
particularly can be very short and
Trevor Bauer could have bounced through
about 17s rather than going from Arizona
in one year to Cleveland and then having
them stay with him and you know he was
it's he's 26 years old so okay they were
patient Corey Kluber won his second game
in the major leagues at the age of at
the age of 26
Kalas Carrasco won his fifth game in the
major leagues at the age of 26 the
Indians are I think they're close to the
best organization in baseball given the
amount of money they have to spend but I
also think
just to be able to be able to develop
patiently young players especially young
pitchers be able to do it and have an
entire pitching staff who makes less
money than about 10 different starters
in the major leagues including including
David Price it's absolutely remarkable
and and he just has so much depth and
they're really fun I think sorry
Franklin understand I was a wonderful
quote from him after last night's game
and I wish the president itíd States
could read it and get it but Issa he
said you know I mean I do what I do I do
what I believe in but I don't get up in
the morning and worry about what people
think about it I I did it I did what I
wanted to do I got up and I live with it
and move on from there and I really I
really believe that he he allows players
to breathe and not worry about the past
he just goes on to the future and I
think you know when you dwell in the
past and you dwell what worked long you
can end up just sort of being in
quicksand and and and he's his future is
gonna be in Cooperstown there's no
question about that Peter Gammons couple
more minutes left with Peter Gammons
here I had I had an interview with Jerry
Seinfeld a couple of weeks ago Peter and
he talked about how much he what what he
enjoys about baseball is what he calls
the democracy of talent and physique
where this is a sport where you can have
two MVP candidates in one being a six
foot seven former tight end kid out in
right field and Erin judge and then you
can have Jose Altuve who is about a buck
80 soaking wet if that the democracy of
talent and physique it's just a
beautiful thing to watch
Altuve is he your MVP over judge or so
close because I think I look at two ways
one l2v went wire-to-wire he was
consistent all year long and I think
that's a great deal to be said for that
when you play 162 games judge came up
for them for the Yankees in about three
or four different times in the
just began to stroke during the season
and he became sort of a beacon for all
those young players the Yankee chef and
they have great young talent and I I end
up saying I think Altuve just because of
that wire wire business or how
consistent the Astros were during the
season but it's really fun saying I I
love that I wish I'd follow that term
I'm I'm really jealous but it's no
bother me the rest of the afternoon told
Peter I'll take it it's it's brilliant
isn't a democracy of talent and physique
is what he said I love that because
that's one of the things about people so
last year when the Red Sox won Bennett
nd they said well he's a little small I
said yeah he's about the same height and
about 15 pounds lighter that car
Yastrzemski was at 37 but it's not about
height and size and all that I mean it's
about its it's about the skill level and
always we used look at this team though
fortunately Pedroia's you know playing
really hurt but Pedroia was the MVP and
American League and he's five foot five
and a half and Altuve could be the MVP
this time but they both have one of the
things that I love about hitters Buck
Showalter thought the this to me about
25 years ago look for guys with short
arms because I can handle a fastball on
the inside part of the plate much better
they don't have to they don't have the
elongated swings even though obviously
the judge and Stanton have incredible
power and have the ability to get the
bat in position to barrel it up but Isis
shorter arms so it's a big advantage and
I think we see that Altuve and Pedroia
classic examples and it's it really is
fun and I also really enjoy the youth
and exuberance so they owe
Houston's in the middle of playing a
nine game series or the Red Sox right
now and it's rice so it's it's really
fun to watch it but I'm telling you
I mean the actuals are just so much fun
I mean they they absolutely they enjoy
things so much George Springer plays
like a maniac
all the time and he made a great catch
yesterday with a score like 7 to 2 he's
great a lot you go yeah try try to kill
himself but that's just the way he is
that's great to watch oh man they got
Gattis who looks like you know Paul
Bunyan and they've got all these young
guys and then older ones like you know
beltron is there with you no McCann it's
it's really just a fun and I play him
Pleasant is like his Perot in a second I
mean he is so fun he's a great I need a
great player an AJ Hinch to me I got
that chance to interview him a couple of
times I've really really came away
impressed and root for him and and I
think it's gonna wind up being Houston
and Cleveland that's gonna be a hell of
a series with two managers who I think
are on the top of their game and we'll
see what happens in the National League
Peter I'm really excited about all of it
and please do before you know I let you
go take take Seinfeld's comment and run
with it go for it I love that it's
beyblade days are fantastic till now
that the game sorry okay very good enjoy
them enjoy all four of them Peter that's
okay thanks so much
always always it's Peter Gammons at P
gamo the Rich Eisen show weekdays at
noon eastern on radio stations across
the country and audience
isn't it amazing you can download an app
with your thumbprint you should download
our app with your thumbprint